>> While he's setting that up,
I can quickly introduce
our group as the rebel alliance.
We weren't really
an officially sanctioned group,
but all of us have
an interest in urban issues,
urban quality of life issues,
and getting city
administrators and
municipalities to make
more citizen-centered decisions,
and so we organically
came together.
The folks represented in
this group include IIT Bombay,
Ashoka University,
Microsoft Research,
and Lakeer, which is
an urban governance
nonprofit that I run.
Why does it matter
to us so much that
city administrators are making
good quality decisions or not?
The context is that
India has actually
already become an urban country.
This is not officially
recognized there in
government records,
but when you look
at satellite data,
depending on how you cut
it, about 55 percent to
78 percent of India is already
urban and we're growing
very, very rapidly.
1,800 Indians move to a city
every hour in search of
better opportunities
and often the quality
of life that they
meet in these cities
are not up to mark.
That's because the folks who run
these cities or
municipalities basically,
they're under-resourced
and under-capacitated,
and are naturally in a place
where they can make good,
smart decisions about where to
prioritize their limited budgets.
So, common area of
interests between the work
that IIT Bombay has been doing,
Ashoka University has been
doing, and Lakeer has been doing,
is that data-driven
decision making can
really improve
the current state of
being off affairs and lead to
more equitable quality of life.
But the question is
really, where is the data?
All of us were
inspired by the work
that Professor Ganesh
presented yesterday talking
about grievance data because it
then struck as that
actually grievance data is
some data that's available across
all urban areas in India,
especially with populations
more than 25,000.
This data is somewhat real-time.
It's collected by
government agencies,
as well as by the private sector,
and it's refreshed
at a regular rate,
and it's also available
back in the past,
going back at least
three, four years.
What's unfortunate is that today,
this data is basically
used as a to-do list.
So, I can show you
what it looks like.
This is all of the grievances
received by the city of
Hyderabad in the last one
month and basically the way
that the city uses
this data is in
each individual point as
one item to mark off on
a to-do list saying,
"This complaint came
in and we acted on it,
there's nothing else
done beyond that."
The questions we started asking
ourselves in the group
yesterday is,
what if we could do
more with this data?
What if we could analyze
this data to figure out
where to prioritize our resources
in a little more intelligent way?
To give you an example
of why that is
needed for a city like Hyderabad,
the annual municipal budget per
citizen per year is
only 800 rupees.
So, exactly equal distribution
of this money will get
us exactly nowhere,
so that prioritization is needed.
The second, what if you
could cross tabulate
this grievance data with
other datasets like budgets,
like tenders to figure
out if there are
some underlying patterns to why
these grievances are coming
up in the first place,
and therefore maybe prevent them
from happening with
better urban planning.
The third is, what
if we could predict
hotspots in spaces as
well as in time of
where grievances
are more likely to occur,
so that the limited number of
government personnel that do
exist can be deployed
more effectively.
But there are barriers
to getting there.
The first, and a lot
of these Professor
Ganesh spoke about,
so I'm going to go
through this quickly.
So, data is not
properly geolocated.
It is of inconsistent quality,
people use different words
from across different languages,
different sentiments to
describe the same problem.
The data is not inter-linked.
So, in the same city,
grievance data will
be reported to multiple
government agencies,
multiple private
agencies, and there's
no one common place where
all of this comes and rests.
Social media data is
not being collated even
though there are a lot
of government agencies
in India now that
actively respond to
complaints on Twitter.
Many of you will be familiar
with the Mumbai police is
a good example of that.
Big, big ethical problem.
Grievance data relies on
people to have agency to
report whether it's through
the web or through phone calls,
and that tends to be
predominantly in areas that are
better off versus
low-income location.
So, there's a huge bias problem.
Then finally, multi-modal data
analysis is not done because,
for instance, in Hyderabad,
about 40 percent of
the complaints that come in,
come in via phone, and
that speech was not
analyzed separately.
So, where does AI come in?
Again, Professor Ganesh spoke
about some of this when it comes
to augmenting and organizing
the grievance database.
So, understanding the complaints,
separating signals from
noise is one potential area.
Just to give you a scale of
the number of complaints
that annually come
in for a city such as
Bangalore or Hyderabad,
we're looking at
annually about half
a million individual complaints.
So, this is not something
that can be manually done.
There is the problem of
figuring out what people are
saying versus what
they actually mean.
We saw this example yesterday,
when Professor described
the problem of cows
on the road versus how
people actually reported.
There's a problem of a lot of
vernacular data that's typed in
English and then
can't be analyzed.
There's a lot of analysis
that goes missing in terms
of which entity
the problem is being
reported about and what
is actually the nature
of the problem,
summarization of the
data that's coming in.
The other issue that I could
potentially help with is give us
richer insights
through cross-tabbing.
This is an example of that.
So, three different datasets
have been combined here.
So, the red dots that you see are
individual grievances of
water logging when it rains.
The terrain map along with
these streams is basically
a watershed analysis
to show what parts
of the city are likely
to flood when it rains.
The black dots that
you see are basically
rehabilitation centers
that have been identified
for this city for where citizens
should be relocated
if there is flooding.
One thing that crops
up is a lot of
the rehabilitation
centers are actually
located in areas, which
are going to flood.
So, insights like these come
out more obviously when there
is cross-tabbing of data.
We see huge potential
to, for example,
bring in a lot of information
from OpenStreetMaps,
layer this on top of
the grievance data,
and find such patterns.
So, the project that
we would like to scope
out and it's still
very much exploratory,
it's not as concrete as
some of the other teams
that have presented
because like I said,
we came together
quite organically.
But basically, in
the first three months,
we want to focus on developing
base maps for urban areas.
So, get some common datasets
in place in terms of
the jurisdictions,
roads, boundaries, what
are the public assets.
We want to develop some standards
around geolocations that can
be adapted across the partners
that at least we
are working with.
So, for example, between us,
we're working with
four city municipalities and
three private sector
organizations
that's saw our grievance data.
Automate the data categorization,
and summarization,
and begin predicting what are
likely hotspots of grievances.
From there, what we want to do
is move onto
cross-tabbing this data
with other potential datasets
like jurisdictions,
budgets, standards.
One question that we
ask in our group is,
what if we could take
the potholes database,
put it on top of
the tenders database,
and find a link between
the contractors who are building
the roads that have
more potholes again and again,
and so they could be penalized?
Figure it out if there's a way to
do more intelligent
prioritization
of the geographies of focus
and the issues of focus.
Finally, in the last six months,
get two multi-modal analysis
across multiple data sources.
So, not just text,
but also image and audio,
and look if it's possible to do
some decentralized action
around grievances.
So, not everything needs to
necessarily read out back to
the government for action.
Some things could come to
civil society organizations,
some things could go
to citizen groups.
Because we didn't have an NGO
at the center of it all,
we had to come up with who
the potential implementation
partners are.
So, what we're thinking
right now is that
IIT Bombay will take a lead on
automating the grievance database
augmentation and organization,
and from that surfacing,
what are some
actionable insights.
What we looked at Lakeer is
get focused on cross-tabbing
this grievance data
with other datasets
that could be scrapped
or RTI-ed from the government.
Ashoka University will
basically focus more on
municipal works and
testing products
through the chief ministers,
good governance,
associate fellows.
The test I've said that
prioritizing for this are
the municipalities in Mumbai,
Bangalore, and Hyderabad.
That brings me to the end
of the presentation.
>> So, for the multi-modal data,
what specifically with the data
which comes over the phone?
Why not have a human
sitting over there?
[inaudible] interface to tag
that data and then why
you need AI for it?
>> Yes. It's a great question.
I'll also let Professor
Ganesh to comment.
So, the government
data that comes in,
that's how it works.
There's a call center.
>> Yes.
>> I think the private
sector guys may
not be able to afford it.
>> Yes.
Besides the point of not
being able to afford,
I think even if some AIs
used to cleanup
the audio that comes
in and basically bootstrap
around the user feedback,
were there repetitive
corrections that are made by
the repetitive patterns that
emerge in the process of
transcription by a human,
can that release automated by,
and this is our of experience
with this project,
it's IIT Bombay Call
Spoken Tutorial.
Now, there's a lot of
speech data and text.
We realized that the very
common accentuated patterns
that could be actually
captured through AI.
So, I agree and most
reliable thing we'll
do, we'll get a human.
But can we get an AI
to assist the human.
>> There was also
another project by
IBM called Spoken Web that also
did tag certain texts
from the verbal calls
that had made.
I'm not sure whether
you guys are aware of,
but it allowed you
to search through
a particular word and then
you can search
the whole voice database.
Unfortunately,
that project is over,
I don't know whether IBM
is actually taking it.
>> It began when I
left IBM research.
>> Okay. I know
Nintendra and all working
on to it, so yes.
>> I was just saying that we
see this as a phase two of
vendor for all of the things
we've been talking about.
There are some individual
pieces of code
that all three of
us have been anyway putting
in the public domain.
So, we're trying to
see through this now,
how all of that can
come together and
become something greater. Yes.